hello and thanks to everybody for coming
indoors on a beautiful winter day if you
probably had to stop at the Girl Scouts
cookie stand on the way in but at least
you're in here thanks a lot for coming I
handed out a time line before we started
to give you a little bit of a sense of
why I chose to write about 1924 I don't
know if there were enough to go around
you can maybe share them if you take a
look at that you see that we're talking
about the early period of Hitler's
political life not the Third Reich the
war and the Holocaust but the first
fourteen years leading up to his seizure
of power in 1933 this period was 14
years long it was coincident with the
Vimal Republic almost started one year
later than the by my Republic and it
breaks more or less into two big parts
the first part as you can see there's
the the Revolutionary part the first
four years leading up to the Beer Hall
Putsch in 1923 and the second big part
is the eight years starting in 1925 sort
of the long march to power the electoral
period he also called he was also
referred to as the legal period the
first four years he was trying to gain
power illegally through a revolution the
last eight years through legal means
more or less not counting the street
fighting between these two periods lies
1924 in my research before I even
decided to do to do this book I noticed
that 1924 seemed to me to be a somewhat
neglected period of the Hitler saga and
on top of that I noticed that it seemed
to be a very important period appeared
when Hitler's Arc political Arc shifted
and he shifted from being an impetuous
revolutionary to being a patient
political player he had time in prison
to reflect on on the error of his ways
and and on the the fact that he was
probably not going to be able to
persuade the military to join him in a
coup and that he had to figure out some
other way to gain power and he said to
one of his friends in prison ouch out
voting them will take longer than out
shooting
but at least the result will be
guaranteed by their Constitution he was
very clear about using the democratic
process to to arrive at an undemocratic
end he said at another point we will
participate in Parliament for the
purpose of taking it and destroying it
these these things were not secrets and
when I began this research I was I was
surprised by some of the things I came
across I had no idea for instance that
the attempted Beer Hall Putsch in
November of 1923 was such a close-run
thing this was not a comic opera event
it was not a drunken brawl in a beer
hall beer halls were used for political
meetings all the time in Bavaria
especially at that time and but for a
few tactical errors Hitler might have
succeeded a lot more than he did he
might have at least taken bavaria
whether he would have taken berlin or
not is uncertain but a few things went
wrong and the butcher's you know ended
in gunfire on the following day and
hitler was almost killed another one of
the many what-ifs along the way of the
hitler biography that could have changed
history but the man next to him was
killed instead another surprise to me
was that hitler had threatened suicide
three times during the night of the bush
and another surprise was that he tried
suicide even as he was being captured
two days later when he got into prison
38 miles west of munich in the town of
Landsberg he went into a suicidal
depression his only recourse at that
point was suicide by starvation he
staged a hunger strike for 10 days until
he was finally talked out of it and then
he began a period of contemplation and
reflection in sort of a forty days and
nights in the wilderness period as I
like to think of it during which he
wrote a 60 page document which is lost
to history but we know he did it through
certain things that came out in his
trial and which was kind of a run-up to
both his trial speeches and to the
writing of mine Kampf and during this
period of two and a half months of
working on this
document he regained his mojo so to
speak and in his case the mojo was a
messianic Savior complex he believed he
could he was the only one who could
really save Germany and began to regain
the confidence which had made him a
dictatorial leader of an upstart party
in the first place I was also surprised
to learn that in his trial which came in
the fourth month he had been allowed to
make a nearly four-hour speech which
basically riveted the courtroom the
judge felt he had to let Hitler have the
run of the courtroom for a variety of
complicated reasons which are all
explained in the book and then at the
end of the trial he made another two and
a half hour speech and in between he was
up and down quite a bit in German Court
procedure then and now the defendants
are allowed to question witnesses and
Hitler did so to the point of driving
one of the most important witnesses
right out of the courtroom a lieutenant
general I was also surprised to learn
that Hitler had written minecraft not
dictated it as legend has it and he
wrote it on a Remington portable
typewriter that had been made just one
month earlier in New York and it was
given to him by a wealthy patroness in
Berlin the wife of a piano manufacturer
named Bechstein right yes thank you
Gerry he had so many patrons and
patroness is that it's hard to keep up
sometimes and I was also surprised to
learn that he wrote Mein Kampf in four
and a half months I mean this is the
first volume of mine comfor I didn't
even know until I got into this that
there are in fact two volumes although
you usually buy it as a one volume book
and I'm going to show you one in a few
minutes
and that another big surprise was that
Hitler almost blew his early release
from prison which is crucial to his
later career because he lusted so much
after a new shiny Benz touring car there
was a Benz because Mercedes and Benz had
not
combined so there were a lot of
interesting surprises for me in the
early stages of the research and that
convinced me as the timeline shows you
that there was a book to be written here
let's back up for a second and and talk
about how it came to pass that Hitler
staged a Beer Hall Putsch 1923 was the
honest or rebus of the vemma republic in
the in the whole 14-year period no year
was worse than that year in January the
French and the Belgians had invaded the
Ruhr area Germany's industrial heartland
hyperinflation began to take off passive
resistance followed by active resistance
led to reprisals by the French including
executions of Germans farmers refused to
release their stores because of
inflation people weren't getting food or
couldn't afford food people went on
hunger strikes German police were
shooting at hungry Germans things were
just basically going to hell in a
handbasket in the worst sort of way and
the political turmoil obviously followed
from that political instability to the
point that Bavaria was almost in a state
of mutiny in fact you could say pretty
certainly and I do in the book that the
Reich's fear read division in Bavaria
was in a state of mutiny against the
rice Fair headquarters in Berlin they
were looking down their gun barrels at
each other by fall of 1923 a complex
concatenation of political forces were
in play all explained in chapters 3 & 4
which led to the point that Hitler felt
he had to act or or he was going to be
outflanked and that other forces in
German politics particularly in Bavaria
might stage a coup and steal a march on
him he found an unexpected opportunity
just when he was deciding he had to act
and he planned he had a complex plan for
doing it on Saturday and Sunday because
half the cops are off and people sleep
late and it would all work out just
great when he heard
that on Thursday night there was a major
speech being held in this big beer hall
the burger boy Keller in the east side
of Munich which holds three thousand
people and the speech would be by the
civilian head of government who was in
fact a dictator at that point it's
complicated but it's explained in the
book and along with him would be the two
military heads of the Bavarian
government at the time the triumvirate
would be under one roof and one time
easy to grab and that's what he did so
that's why the beer hall that's why the
push started in a beer hall rather than
as it was originally planned in the
traditional way of taking over the
police stations and the radio stations
and stuff like that in the middle of the
night so Hitler marches in fires his
pistol into the ceiling and takes the
place by storm convinces after a while
these three men that they have to join
him in his coup and his plan for a march
on Berlin the idea for a march on Berlin
comes from the Mussolini model of the
march on Rome a year earlier it also is
connected to the revolutionary style of
Kemal Pasha later known as Ataturk who
staged his revolution in Turkey from
outside the capital he declared a new
government in Ankara and and rather than
face the existing government the Ottoman
government head-on in constantinople
istanbul and it worked and so Hitler had
that in mind to starting a revolution
outside the capital was part of his
model and he openly copied Kemal Pasha
in that regard but in the course of the
night his comrade-in-arms general
ludendorf the hero of World War one
goofed and he let the triumvirate yo
they had been taken hostage by Hitler he
let him loose in the middle of the night
on their words of honor as officers
Ludendorff was very much a man of the
old school and a German officers word of
honor counted for everything well but
these guys as soon as they got out of
course they turned coat again
and Hitler
who failed in the middle of the next day
he and ludendorff decided they had to
play their last card which was to
attempt to attract popular support by
marching through the center of Munich
and they figured if they could get some
sort of an uprising going that would
turn the tide the other way
in fact as they marched through the city
they did get a lot of support people
were cheering them and they were jeering
the police and Bavarian state forces
which were trying to control them in the
end however they came just to the other
side of the center of town to the Odeon
square beside the so called field
marshal's Hall Memorial and there was a
cordon of bavarian state police who went
into a kneeling position ordered hitler
and his men to stop they didn't the
police fired the result was 15 of
hitler's men were killed four policemen
and one bystander and that then led to
hitler's capture two days later and his
time in prison his time in prison is
very interesting mark mentioned the
whole business of prisoners hardening
their beliefs in prison under hard time
in fact in this case Hitler hardened his
beliefs under soft time Germany had then
a form of imprisonment called honorable
imprisonment except they call it
fortress arrest but that word fortress
is very confusing you'd best forget it
there's a picture in the book which
shows you why was note by no means of
fortress where he was imprisoned but
that is the actual name in German and
under this form of arrest the prisoners
had rooms that were more like dorm rooms
or sort of you know junior college dorm
rooms maybe they had open doors all day
they had four to six hours of outdoor
time every day they could wear their own
clothes and they got better food than
the rest of the prisoners in the prison
which held 500 other regular criminal
inmates it was during this time however
that Hitler had a lot of time to read
and talk and walk around in the garden
you'll see a picture of him in the book
walking in the garden with one of his
pals looking a little porky
in his later hose and shorts and this
was because Hitler got a lot of visitors
more than 350 during his 13 months in
prison many of them women and many of
them all of them really bearing gifts
and the gifts were often is not a play
for Hitler's famous sweet tooth and the
famous German Cohen or baked goods
pastries and he'd put on some say up to
ten pounds while he was in prison in any
case he did use this time for reflection
and then he when he regained his mojo as
I said earlier keep in mind that this is
an extremist this is a crazy what we now
regard as a crazy guy in his case that
meant conquering the world he hadn't
openly declared messianic complex and he
just began writing grand things and
making grand speeches and finally after
the trial decided it was time to write
this down there are several accounts of
what may have got him going on the book
one is that one of the fellow prisoners
had gotten sick and tired of Hiller
dominating all the evening conversations
and dinnertime conversations with his
monologues Hiller only knew one kind of
conversation him talking monologues
there's a whole book called monologues
of his table his table talk later in the
later in the 30s and 40s in the 40s and
Hitler that story may be apocryphal
there's another reasonable speculation
that he needed the money
we know he needed the money he wrote one
letter saying my lawyers bills make my
hair stand on end just like many other
prisoners in history have written no
doubt but I think the main reason was
the man needed to talk and he had an
audience of only 40 other guys his his
fellows who were also convicted of their
activities in the bush and that's not a
big enough audience for a guy like
Hitler so he wanted to write this book
in addition he wanted to legitimize
himself in the eyes of the world this
was a guy who dropped out of high school
never got any kind of degree or diploma
in any
was rejected for art the Arts Academy in
Vienna and even though he clearly was an
autodidact extremely widely read very
smart a quicker mind than anybody in
most rooms and a widely eclectic command
of data and information and a famously
strong memory even though he had all
that he had no credentialing and so he
unloaded it all in this book which he
wrote furiously for four and a half
months Rudolf Hess in one of his letters
home said I give him tea at 5:00 in the
morning there are other reports for him
and for me and Hitler is banging away I
I queried that a little bit wondering
well how would the other forty guys put
up with that and the answer I got back
was remembered most of these guys were
soldiers in World War one that's a huge
shaping element in this that I have left
out by the way World War one
you know without World War one there is
no Hitler I think most historians would
tell you certainly Sir Ian Kershaw has
said that and I quote him in the book
and so they were used to early morning
activity and early morning noises
ex-soldiers and then he would often work
until midnight for which he had to pay
an extra fee to keep the lights turned
on since the curfew was at ten o'clock
everybody else had to turn their lights
off at 10:00 but he was able to keep his
own until 12:00 if he paid a little fee
and from time to time he would read
parts of this book to Hess that's where
the myth arose by the way that he had
dictated the book to Hess some fabulous
research has been done by a scholar and
Austrian in looking who showed that it
was impossible for him to have dictated
this to Hess and that the whole legend
started with one prison guard sighting
one moment when he heard Hitler's vote
in torreón voice coming through the
closed door of Hess's cell or maybe was
Hitler cell either way they were both in
that room
so he said Hitler's dictating to Hess
and that has stuck with us for
sixty-five years before it was knocked
down by better research
what he was doing was reading to Hess if
you examined the Hess letters you find
out that Hitler made a habit of reading
to Hef's Hess became his sounding board
you know Hess was by comparison with
most of the guys in the prison an
educated man came from an upper
bourgeois family had been raised in
Egypt and his father was a big merchant
and so they had this back and forth and
then it gets kind of complicated and he
and Hess have a little falling-out
that's about chapter 10 I think
and Hitler has finished this book by
about September starting in late April
and is looking for a publisher there's a
little bidding war and he ends up going
with the Nazi publisher who had no money
at the time turned out to be a good
decision he turned down the other offers
he had and by keeping it in the family
so to speak he became a very rich man
this book sold 12 million copies before
he died in any case at the same time
Hitler had been looking at his window a
line he was on a second floor yeah
second floor that I was there a year ago
this month in fact yeah the bars are the
same you'll see a picture of him
standing by the window twice in the book
nothing has changed about the cell that
way the inner walls are all gone it's
just a big open room now but the but the
outer walls and windows are the same and
from this window you can see over the
prison wall because it's on the second
floor he could see cars going back and
forth you know a few hundred yards away
there was a an important road connecting
lines back to the next town and he was
he was a sucker for beautiful cars you
know he had a even though he was anti
modernist in many ways he did have a
weakness for technology and particularly
cars and so he got his heart set on
getting a new car and probably a
chauffeur by the time he got out and he
started haggling with the local bents
dealer even though he had no money and
he had the local Benz dealer who's whose
garage they called as his dealership
happened to be on the same street as the
furnisher borough bhakta the Nazi
newspaper in Munich Shailesh the famous
shilling Strasse come to visit him in
prison in September and they talked
about
whether he needed the 40 horsepower of
the 50 horsepower in what color and
white wall tires and all this stuff and
the guy left and Hitler quickly wrote
him a letter saying please take this to
the top to Mannheim which is where the
Benz headquarters was and see if you can
get me a discount you know I've got
these lawyers bills and 20,000 marks is
too much and all this stuff like any one
of us in any dealership on Rockville
Pike here's the future head of the Nazi
Party who's on the same typewriter that
has just written mine Kampf
he's haggling for a deal on a new bench
but he needs to get this letter into the
guy's hands on Monday and they've been
meeting on Saturday or Friday he wrote
the letter on Saturday anyway the only
way to make make it fit was to smuggle
the letter out you know mail in Europe
as many of you know often was delivered
on the same day in those days so if he
got it into the mail in Munich on Monday
morning the guy would have it by Monday
night that was the only way to catch him
before he went to mine this letter made
it but some other things happened that
exposed the smuggling and because of
that Hitler's planned release at the end
of September were stopped and there
ensued a dramatic two and a half month
kind of court struggle with the
prosecutor trying to do everything he
could to keep Hitler behind bars another
one of the great what-ifs if the
prosecutor as well as the Munich police
put forward all sorts of arguments about
why Hitler should not be released or at
the very least he should be deported to
Austria which under the law he should
have been in any case for having staged
a coup attempt even if he hadn't been
convicted he should have been deported
and after about a three month back and
forth well sure I'll give it away yeah
they let him out and that then was of
one more stepping stone that propelled
Hitler quickly back into the political
stream of things at a critical time when
he could then restart the Nazi Party
remade in his own image and very much
under his own thumb let me see here yeah
now I want to go quickly to one other
thing many of you have heard about the
republication of mine Kampf in Germany
and many of you may that was about a
month ago and about a week ago stories
circulated that all of a sudden it had
become a best-seller
in Germany and this happens to be true
and it's a very it was an unexpected
bestseller and my dear wife is passing
out some documents they're not enough to
go around so if you maybe every other
person keep one which will help you
understand what I'm about to explain and
the book was published by an academic
institution in Germany for the first
time in 70 years because the copyright
finally ran out and the Bavarian
government could no longer block the
republication of mine Kampf the fact
that it has become a best-seller is
taken by many at first glance to be a
bad sign does this mean there are Nazi
tendencies again what about the rise of
anti-immigrant feeling in the last
couple of months and in the backlash
against the immigrant wave in the
refugee wave I see it just the opposite
I think it is a good thing and I'm going
to explain it with a little with a prop
here in a second
bear with me a second okay this is mine
come this is the two volumes in one book
782 pages and this is a fairly typical
book jacket that was used at the time
although there were a thousand print
more than a thousand printings and the
covers changed and a lot of things
change but this is a very typical
looking version of it this is the one I
used in 1943 people's Edition so this is
what I call now the old Mein Kampf this
is the new mine Kampf remember when
Ronald Reagan did that with the budget
many years ago
twelve pounds six pounds each like the
inside this is Volume one that's why
them to the other way around and what
this is is a totally academically
annotated version of Mein Kampf
this is 1966 pages long the footnoting
and annotations as you can see on the
sheet outnumber the Hitler's words by a
longshot and the way it's been organized
has been compared to the Talmud it was
Dan McMann at the yad vashem museum
first brought that to my attention a
year and a half ago and in fact inside
the this volume there's a picture of an
old Bible and as you see from the
highlighted section
those are Hitler's words and then all
the rest is the commentary and that one
is not even I mean they're that example
which they posted online you know here's
an example that here's an example that
has even more
footnoting in some cases the footnoting
goes over to another full spread so you
have three and a half pages of footnotes
to go with this much text and if you
look at a Talmud or look at the example
in the front of this book you'll see
it's very much like an old Bible II and
what this just to wrap up quickly here
what this thing has done in my opinion
has is they've destroyed my account and
I say this having spent quite a bit of
time with this new version first of all
you can't read the damn thing because
you're always being interrupted one
small page had seven footnotes which
takes you know 20 minutes just to read
the footnotes this is all in German by
the way but English translations will
come in a while and the first two pages
for example of nation and race the most
notorious chapter in the first volume of
mine Kampf have 15 footnotes and the
footnotes run up to a hundred to two
hundred and fifty words so this is
serious stuff this is the real deal and
the footnotes have footnotes I don't
want to be overdoing it here but this is
scholarly work now it's still the
question still remains well well first
of all no self-respecting neo-nazi would
buy this thing right and why you can get
the real thing the real Hitler is a pure
Hitler for free on the internet there's
a download and when you try reading
Hitler with all these interruptions and
footnotes you don't get Hitler you get
this broken up thing which is totally
deconstructed you know because they show
the context they show the lies they show
the half-truths and all of these things
which make it pretty much impossible to
get with the flow of Hitler so I think
my time on all of this stuff is sort of
run out but I want to thank you for
listening and I'm happy to take some
questions
[Applause]
so it's show time we're on c-span hope
we have some curious voices yes ma'am
I'll be first I was reading your
acknowledgments and I'm always amazed on
these Hitler or World War 2 books just
the incredible amount of research that
has to go into it and I noticed you
mentioned a graduate student who had
been sort of your research assistant
could you talk to me about the role of
your research assistant how you found
this graduate student what they actually
did for you
I started off thank you I started off by
querying the Institute's for
contemporary history in Munich which
published the main Kampf for
recommendations of for an intern or
somebody an assistant who could help me
and this one came through because this
student grad student had already been
working for them for a while she
actually was a Canadian not a German but
she's totally fluent in German was just
finishing her master's in German and
turned out to be a great find and the
best single thing she did for me was
reach out through her network to a
historian who then told us about a book
over here which turned out to be a 500
page 2 volume scrapbook of clippings
from Hitler's trial let me just say it
came as a huge stunning surprise to me
that nobody has ever written a book
about this trial it's one of the most
important trials in history really when
you consider the consequences and plenty
of people actually said that at the time
no book in German no book in English and
you have two main sources for this
information one is the trial transcript
which thank God somebody put together 20
or 30 years ago and the other is these
clippings now if I had had to go find
all these clippings individually it's
very hard remember Germany was at war a
lot of stuff is lost but somebody had
made a scrapbook so I have about 500
actual clippings day by day by day there
was a press corps of more than 60
reporters every day German reporters
every day at Hitler's trial the trial
was over
five weeks 25 trial days so you can
imagine the amount of reporting and it
was lovely
reporting wonderful writing lively
writing it gives you everything the
trial transcript does not give you so
you know - Courtney Burrell and Munich I
give great thanks for that still yes sir
right in any way did you write this book
as a cautionary tale not to mention any
names well I started two years ago so I
could not quite foresee what would be
happening at this stage of the political
campaign but I'm happy for it to be
taken that way and anybody who does any
research on Hitler or the Third Reich or
any of this period is if so facto
writing a cautionary tale yes sir I've
read mine come for a couple of times
over the years and the one thing that
sticks in my mind is he came up saying
Hitler said that no political leader has
ever reached the heights of his career
except for the spoken word and I was
wondering and I had hurt I grew up in
Switzerland so heard him speak years ago
and you know the mesmerizing deliverer
he had where in fact did he come up with
that as a concept and also did he learn
any of that did he
did somebody teach him or how did he
come up with it well I would say
instinctively and that's one of the
reasons he was such a huge success he
did say that he did say no revolution
has ever been brought about by writing
he said this in writing and and you know
he put it down even as he was doing it
he did say by the way I forgot to
mention he called his time in prison my
university education at state expense
true and this was his dissertation and
he had already of course been making
speeches for four years when he was in
prison and said that I'm trying to
remember that was in mine comfor in one
of the speeches but in mine country goes
on at great length about speaking and
propaganda and it's almost it's a
handbook for other Nazis in many ways
who lead the local groups and the state
groups
and he says that over and over again
that the spoken word is what makes the
difference and the individual
personality he had several you know
rules like that about the importance of
propaganda and they served him pretty
well for a long time
unfortunately Roger unique okay I want
to ask you two blank questions first of
all why was the sentence so short what
were the considerations at play there
and secondly do you think if the
sentence had been what we would think of
as a reasonable length considering what
he was trying to do if he either been
deported or kept in jail for let's say
ten years that the Hitler we knew never
would have materialized he's in the
second question first and the answer is
yes but that's speculative naturally but
most people who I'm sorry the question
was how why did he get such a short
sentence for after he was convicted of
treason and the answer to that is that
he almost didn't get even that the trial
was skewed from the beginning by the
choice of the judge who was a known
right winger who had already pardoned
another the guy who assassinated Kurt
Eisner the former Bavarian governor who
had been sentenced to death and this
judge then pardoned him and gave him
soft time honorable imprisonment and had
in fact given Hitler parole for an
earlier crime that Hitler committed
basically in breach of the peace for
bashing the head of an opponent in a
beer hall one time Hitler should have
also been convicted of violating his
parole but wasn't so that so the this
the fix was sort of in from the
beginning by the choice of this judge at
the same time the Bavarian authorities
as you will read were wringing their
hands about how lenient he was being
during the trial it's a complicated
thing they had a so-called People's
Court still in operation this was next
to the last trial they did before they
went out of business which included lay
judges
three lady judges the judge needed four
votes to convict the late judges were so
taken with Hitler and his speeches that
they didn't want to convict him at all
so the head judge the the right winger
had to convince them that we got to do
this
you can't not commit he basically
admitted to the deed but he denied the
crime he said yeah I tried to overthrow
the government but it's no crime because
those guys are criminals anyway you know
in his he called him the November
criminals the whole vibe our government
was based on a crime in his opinion
which was the declaration of or the
proclamation of a republic by the Social
Democrats and November 1918 as Germany
was going down the tubes in the war and
the Kaiser was already gone out of town
so they agreed to the five-year sentence
which was the minimum the the span was
five years to life is what he could have
gotten and the minimum he was able to
get the minimum only by guaranteeing
Hitler almost guaranteeing holding out
the prospect very strongly of parole in
six months and so Hitler lost the trial
and won the war he won the political
battle he lost the legal battle and won
the political battle he emerged from the
trial a hero a political hero and Rogers
other question was whether had he gotten
let's say ten years twenty years might
he have disappeared from the political
landscape my guess is yes and I base
that partly on what many others have
written mark can you come up mark the
story's been attempting to determine for
some time now when Hitler's
anti-semitism became extermination so
now the question is if you were a German
in 1924 and had bought mine Kampf could
you see what was going to happen the
answer is no not the extermination is
part see that's a that's a hugely highly
debated element of the of the Hitler
saga you know even after the Von's a
meeting
how much did Hitler know how much did
Hitler control things you know what we
can say if you bought the book it was
1925 when it was published the first
volume in 26 the second volume all you
would have seen would be rabid
anti-semitism the line that's often
quoted to give a sense of how extreme
Hitler was was near the end of the
second volume in which he is talking
about World War one and what a mess it
was why it shouldn't have happened or
why was run wrongly by the existing
German government and the Kaiser in
which he's and of course he's blaming it
on the stab-in-the-back people and on
the Jewish profit ears etc and he says
if only 12 to 15,000 of these Hebrew
corrupters of the people had been held
under gas at the beginning a million
good German lives would have been saved
well a lot of people have left from that
to the conclusion ah he was going to do
gas chambers but but the experts will
all tell you they don't believe that
that is not you can't make that
connection so you know when he became
elimination ax stand extermination astiz
I don't have the answer to that and it's
way beyond the time that I studied for
sure I think yes
is there a list of books that he read
and that he have favorite authors that
motivated his thinking
great question Teddy thank you this is
another disputed issue in the Hitler
historiography there are claims that he
read all of these big names Schopenhauer
Nietzsche and all sorts of others and
all the classics Goethe etc etc and
there are scholars who have knocked that
down in very specific ways I addressed
this and several paragraphs in the book
I recommend a book by a woman named
Brigitta Hammond called Vienna
Hitler's of Vienna years and then there
is a claim by Hans Frank Hitler's one of
the side cakes that Hitler had read
certain things in prison that is also
subject to serious scrutiny we you know
in Hitler claim for instance have read
every book on a certain bookshop in
Vienna
five hundred books so we don't know and
we do know that he fudged around a lot
in mine cuff and that's one of the
things you learn from these twelve
pounds of of annotations here is is how
convincing sounding stuff was way off or
a little off or he was they called it in
German stylizing making it fit the
picture he wanted to present so I hate
to say it tell you but we don't really
have a clear answer to that on the other
hand through this book in part this book
by the way becomes the footnoted
bibliographic version of Mein Kampf that
Hitler never wrote his book contains
zero footnotes no bibliography and only
three or four or ten maybe attributions
in the whole 800 pages of where he got
an idea if you know even when the
English version of this becomes
available you'll see that he a lot of
his statements and ideas can be traced
back to certain racist writers like hkf
Gunter and then the the classics like
the gobino de la Garde
of the middle of the 19th century so
there there is
this is a very long way of saying there
is a kind of a small Hitler cannon that
you can point to but it takes them some
effort to put it together anything Peter
I have to ask is this stretch or are
there any similarities between the
extreme things that Hitler said and the
ones Trump once Trumper said yeah I knew
I could count on you to bring that I'm
trying to duck and dodge as much as I
can I'm not covering the campaign so I I
know about as much as any of the rest of
you know I'm just gonna say one thing on
this a single and much has been written
I recommend Peter Bergin's piece on the
CNN website I was just looking again
today at my file on this topic waiting
for you to ask that question any it's
this thick you know a month and a half
ago there was a flurry of comparisons of
of Trump to Hitler I had resisted that
getting into that fray because it can be
so dangerous I think to make comparisons
to Hitler but the thing that does strike
me the most about similarities between
those two guys is their their own self
belief Hitler's solution for Germany was
Hitler mr. Trump solution seems to be
Trump you know then there's some other
stuff but mainly it's me me me and only
only I can do it and in fact if you look
at Peter Bergen speech you see a more
scientific typology of the of the the
the science on the great man theory and
and what a messianic complex includes
and it includes that anymore thank you
very much
[Applause]
all right we welcome everyone to come to
the front but please line up to the left
and copies of 1924 on sale at the back
of the register
Oh
[Music]